julio batió el récord del mes más
caluroso en la historia sin embargo
según los expertos olas de calor como
estas serán cada vez más intensas y
duraderas en el momento las más
afectadas son las naciones del
hemisferio norte como ciertas regiones
europeas que se enfrentan a temperaturas
mayores de 48 grados a día de hoy lo que
tenemos un anticiclón en este caso se
llama dulce el anticiclón un nombre muy
apropiado que lo que está haciendo es la
introducción de todo el calor de toda la
calima sahariana
en españa la ola de calor ya está
causando estragos en la salud de los
ciudadanos
al prado y una señora desplomada en una
en una banca nadie la socorro ya corrió
perdón además las altas temperaturas
podrían desembocar más frecuentemente en
incendios como los que azotan el
mediterráneo
turquía lleva 15 días de lucha contra el
fuego que ha cobrado la vida de 30
personas y este sábado la de ocho más
que van en un avión que se cayó buscando
apagar las llamas al sur del país grecia
ha visto cerca de 90.000 hectáreas de
sus bosques calcinadas que a mayor
temperatura los que se llaman las
famosas tres tenor el tiempo la
temperatura y la falta de humedad pues
lo que hace es que provoca la formación
de incendios y si encima la tempera en
la velocidad del viento es muy elevada
esto impide que se sofoque en dicho el
incendio
pero las llamas también afectan a eeuu
en donde el fuego dixie se consolida
como el segundo incendio más grande en
la historia de california devastando
cerca de 209.000 hectáreas
al otro extremo del planeta el
presidente ruso vladimir putin afirmó
este sábado que los desastres naturales
que están viviendo no tienen precedentes
según el grupo intergubernamental de
expertos sobre el cambio climático la
temperatura terrestre ha aumentado en
1.5 grados por lo que de no haber
cambios desastres como estos podrían ser
cada vez más comunes en los años por
venir